[Music]
at the cenotaph they'd come to pay their
respects to the armed forces and the
queen
the national anthem sung with added
poignancy the monarch unexpectedly not
there because she'd sprained her back
it's the 100th anniversary of the royal
british legion and of the poppy and i
think for the queen to miss that one
will have been really upsetting for her
but she will have followed it and she
will have seen that the national act of
remembrance took place in the
traditional form and that's what she
would have cared about
it's always been one of the most
significant moments of her year the
queen has only missed it on six other
occasions when she was on tour and
pregnant
leading the nation in reflection albeit
from the balcony as she's grown older
in her absence this year prince charles
again placed his mother's wreath
tradition is very important but the
royal family can also be incredibly
practical and it was obviously decided
that that car journey from windsor here
to central london and then standing on
that balcony for over half an hour was
just going to be too much for the queen
when she's got a bad back and the
doctors have already told her to rest
the queen was incredibly busy during
october her last public outing the
global investment summit at windsor
castle and then out of the blue a trip
to northern ireland was cancelled and
she spent a night in hospital after
having tests she then pulled out of
other major engagements like cop 26 and
the festival of remembrance which her
family attended instead
it's been so rare for her to miss visits
during her almost 70 year reign it has
caused concern both here and in other
commonwealth realms
everyone will be wishing her well
everyone will want to see her again and
she is the beating heart of most of the
love that is in the commonwealth so we
do wish her well i'm very glad to have
the chance to
see you if only mechanically this
morning
the palace have wanted to show us that
she is carrying out light duties but
with her already pulling out of next
week's general synod for the church of
england and prince edward attending
instead it is increasingly apparent her
family are having to step up to that
most important role of supporting her
rhiannon mills sky news in central
london